brothers and sisters now someone brought
to my attention this interview with
Piers Morgan and our brother Andrew Tate
because you have recently converted to
Islam correct so these questions are
thinking pertinent to your conversion
absolutely as to what you actually
believe as a practicing Muslim now now I
want to go ahead and share a few parts
from it and give you guys my reaction
and comments on it uh yeah I believe
that Islam is beautiful the interesting
thing is that our brother Andrew starts
off with giving Piers Morgan the
greeting of assalamu alaikum no Andrew
good to see you salam alaikum Pierce
good to see you assalamu alaikum if you
guys didn't know and if Piers Morgan
didn't know it's actually the greeting
of Jesus and Piers Morgan I believe he's
Catholic Christian so I'm sure that if
he Ponders over this greeting he would
appreciate it it's a greeting of all the
prophets and it's a greeting that we
greet each other with which means p
peace be with you assalamu alaikum what
isn't that such a beautiful greeting if
you really think about it
now let's get right into this video with
our brother Andrew Tate and Pierce
Morgan pushing him Piers Morgan is
pushing Andrew Tate on this statement
that he made back when he was an atheist
well here's what you said Isis are the
real Muslims because I sister exactly
what the book says kill everyone is not
a Muslim and chop people's heads off and
set them on fire and be raging lunatics
but all the other Muslims go they're not
real Muslims because I read the book and
ignore those parts well then you're not
an effing Muslim because you're ignoring
the effing book
that's an interesting that's an
interesting point you've just raised
because I am now Islamic and it's it's
funny because I used to be an atheist
and when you're an atheist you believe
that religion causes more problems than
it fixes let's start off with that he
talks about he used to be an atheist and
that's when he made that statement
that's just like Sam Harris now can you
imagine the kind of statements that
Richard Dawkins Sam Harris and the likes
and the list goes on of how many people
who know little to nothing about Islam
who are just repeating what they heard
from the last ignoranus or the hate
provocateur things that are totally the
antithesis to Islam have nothing to do
with Islam but they grab onto this hold
on to this and they spew it and this is
something that our brother fell into
obviously he was atheist he didn't know
about Islam back then and now he's
clarifying this up this is a very
important point and you realize that
religion is actually the cure for most
of the problems in the world and
godlessness is the problem in the world
so that is something I will apologize
for to me I was wrong about because I
was atheistic and now as a Muslim I
understand that's absolutely not the
case if that's a particular video you're
talking about then then well that's
really interesting so you you regret
saying that yeah let's get into the
second important thing that after being
an atheist he realized that there has to
be a god second phase in life he
realizes there has to be a god An
Almighty Supreme Being an Arabic we say
Allah this is an Aramaic the language
that Jesus spoke he would say Allah so
this is the before the people get
freaked out and say oh he what are you
talking about Allah no this is the
creator of the heavens Earth that Jesus
called upon it just blows my mind how
people to this day the majority of
people don't have the proper name of God
they call upon God by God to say who you
praying to God but the English language
at one point did not exist so God in
English can be God's male or female in
the English language the term God can be
referred to for pagan gods Hindu gods
for some people refer to Jesus as God
but when we say Allah this is the one
truly one when we say pure monotheism
the Supreme Being he doesn't become born
he doesn't die he doesn't sleep he
doesn't rest he doesn't eat he doesn't
get tired he doesn't work and then rest
on the seventh day he doesn't become the
creation come down to Creation to get
then get killed by his creation he's the
Creator we're the creation and he is the
one and we say he he's not a male or
female but he is one absolutely one pure
monotheism got it good and then second
phase of his life Andrew Tay goes from
being an atheist and now realize there
has to be a God why because there's so
much evil in the world if there's so
much evil in the world there has to be a
devil and if there's a devil then there
must be a crater of the heavens and
earth there must be a God Allah now
let's get into this next part where now
he ended up going from his state of
jahalia you know he's in his beginning
infancy stages you know he's real he's
already realizing that this is the wrong
statement this group this daesh have
nothing to do those actions have nothing
to do with true Islam so he made that
when he was an atheist he's clearing it
up and now he's going to do the
honorable thing he apologizes and
remember he he doesn't agitate this is
you know this is a sign this is a good
sign of his sincerity here because look
at this many things he doesn't he pushes
back he doesn't apologize on statements
that he's made in the past but this one
he is truly apologizing and inshallah as
he grows in Islam as he gets the right
information the right knowledge and his
taqwa increases his God Consciousness
creases you'll see that inshallah God
willing he's going to do more of what
the Deen tells him to do because he
loves God he wants to please God and
he's going to obey God inshallah so you
you regret saying that yeah because you
learn and you grow and you evolve as I
said at the time I believed it because I
didn't believe in God at the time it was
a very long time ago it's actually kind
of a testament to you peers you managed
to find the oldest possible videos of me
that have ever existed now he's Muslim
he's getting the right information the
right knowledge on the issue that Piers
Morgan is pushing him on so when he's
asked about he apologize she did The
Honorable thing the sincere thing the
right thing and this is what many don't
get to see because now he's seen the
truth but what's stopping people from
seeing the truth is that arrogance that
Kipper that arrogance that people have
and now when they have that arrogance
and that Pride they don't want to get
let go of certain statements that made
he made that statement a long time ago
he's Muslim now he's learned now but
people how they gonna learn grow and
evolve like he did if they're arrogant
and they're holding on to something that
is totally not true it's false so
they're lying to themselves they're
lying to the Creator they're lying to
God they're lying to people and there's
few in these this nonsense but
alhamdulillah it's very nice to see that
he apologized for this he made the
mistake but obviously because now he's
seeing what Islam truly is and as we
know as Muslims you just open up the
Quran chapter 5 verse 32 killing one
innocent being as if you killed the
world saving one innocent being as if
you say the world so you know Islam is
about preserving life preserving
Humanity not destroying Humanity not
wrecking Chaos on the earth of course
you have a right to defend yourself self
and your family but you have no right to
go killing innocent men women and
children and non-combatants no the last
part I want to share with you guys is
his response to peers Morgan on how our
brother Andrew Tate is proud he's proud
to represent his Deen his new way of
life he's proud to be a Muslim and then
he starts giving dawah he starts sharing
how beautiful Islam is how was the last
true Way of Life religion on Earth I was
curious because you have recently
converted to Islam correct so these
questions are thinking pertinent to your
conversion absolutely as to what you
actually believe as a practicing Muslim
now uh yeah I believe that Islam is
beautiful I believe it's the last True
Religion on Earth is certainly the last
respected religion on Earth and I felt
differently inside since I've converted
and I think it has the solutions to a
lot of the problems we're facing in the
world today and this should encourage
other famous Muslims are not so famous
Muslims to be proud of their Deen this
way of life and not to be apologetically
Muslim because as a Muslim you're upon
the truth you're one who has submitted
his or her will to the creator of the
heavens and earth you're on the best way
of life Islam has solutions for all of
Humanity's problems you name it from the
family breakdown racism adultery the STD
epidemic debauchery spiritual emptiness
devoid in the heart the academic of
alcoholism drug abuse social economical
Islam solves it all you name it Islam
solves it and most importantly has the
answer to the billion dollar question
what's the purpose of life why am I here
why have I been created I mean you can
be somebody out there right now watching
this you're a fan of Andrew Tate you
think this is a very intelligent
individual he did his research he did
his homework why don't you look into
Islam and then he also have somebody he
points out this hypocrisy this is also a
very key point I don't find any form of
terrorism satisfying I don't find
Western terrorism satisfying either I
don't think it's satisfying that we
managed to find five hundred thousand
dollars per bomb to drop on some farmer
who makes four dollars a day under the
name of freedom and and we can't seem to
pay our nurses enough to do their jobs I
don't find any kind of terrorism and
it's actually very interesting you talk
about the world terrorism terrorist and
freedom fighter good guy and bad guy all
of this is subjective there are people
who believe that the west of the biggest
terrorists on the Earth are people who
believe that America causes more Wars
than anyone else okay brothers and
sisters and Humanity at Large
you can go ahead and think about ponder
over you know what Andrew Tate is that
feeling now that he's getting and I felt
differently inside since I've converted
you know his intelligence he is a smart
individual why would somebody the most
Google man on Earth and why would he put
his neck on the line why would he even
bring more of this negative attention to
himself you know our people are bashing
Islam or people are lying about Islam he
did his homework on Islam and what does
he say Islam is beautiful yeah I believe
that Islam is beautiful I believe it's
the last True Religion on Earth the true
way of life from the creator of the
heavens and earth why don't you look
into it I'm sure if you a Andrew Tay fan
contact us let's get your feedback on
why you ended up coming to Islam after
you ended up researching it and maybe
that's what kicked it off for you Andrew
Tate so if you're somebody who's
interested you want to know why Andrew
Tate submitted to the will of the
creator of heavens and earth in Islam to
the creator of the heavens and earth
Allah go ahead and also visit us at
thedine show.com we'll get you a free
copy of the Quran this is the last and
final Revelation sent to mankind so
that's your homework now because that's
the crucial question to life what's the
purpose of life why are you here why
have you been created and in Islam is
not Blind Faith you just jump in like
all these other man-made religions Islam
is calling you to think to ponder and
reflect and when you look at all the
evidence that Islam has to offer then
you're just overwhelmed you're like wow
this cannot come from a human being this
cannot come from all of humans coming
together this book indeed is from the
creator of Heaven that's why Andrew Tate
is a Muslim and he submitted his will to
the created heavens and earth in Islam
worshiping the Creator not the creation
you could do the same thing get that
peace satisfaction that feeling now that
he has of the Void being filled and
slowly and slowly you can see you'll
start to give up the alcohol as I heard
he already did slowly now since you
become a Muslim have you stopped
drinking alcohol yes I might drink a
little bit now and again I don't but I
don't think I I don't think I'll ever
and start to bring up get his life will
only get better as long as he has stayed
focused asking for guidance each and
every day and inshallah we'll have him
back on the show look forward to that
inshallah that'll happen very soon and
we'll see you next time until then
subscribe it if you haven't already so
you can get all of these videos when
they come out until next time assalamu
alaikum like when we started
and we'll end with that peace be with
you